the next lifetime i would like to put in
an order for your legs if that's okay i
now have the visual of the legs i have
always wanted should we just trade now
yes they zip up there you go okay great
okay perfect um because i do feel girl
friendy with you and i wonder if that's
something
that uh people sort of um have that
barrier broken with you because of girls
it's literally the 10-year anniversary
and
it's it was so groundbreaking obviously
like we all when we were making girls
were like we think this is really great
and important but like you just never
know and so the fact that it had the
response that it did was like
i mean it was life-changing obviously
and because we all played these
characters that were just like burying
our souls and our bodies and our lives
people felt like they knew us and i
think particularly shashana as a
character who's just so out there and
like unabashed and who she is and is an
over sharer herself
um so
yes i think people felt like they were
my best friend i would get a a lot of
people who didn't necessarily recognize
me from the show but they thought they
knew me so i like i've literally had
showdowns with people in airports where
they're like you went to camp ottawa
with me and i'm like
look i promise
i think i would i would not lie actually
not having gone to summer camp is like a
really sore subject for me because i
didn't get to go i was not in cabinet
with you you're mistaking me for someone
else oh my god i have that same thing i
never got to go to a camp and all i did
was watch meatballs and every camp movie
camp nowhere little little darlings
which is highly inappropriate but like
the best movie ever
um but is it true that you and your
husband live in a cabin
we do yes kind of
part of our house is um the original
structure is this 1920s sears catalog
cabin oh my god i love those um but so
that those are actually the additions to
the house that we didn't put on but the
front of the house is like a legit like
there's not one nail in it it's like a
full-on log cabin that's so cool and is
it true that your husband who is an
actor but also
liaisons as a contractor yes he uh lucky
you i mean you guys i really hit the
jackpot he's also a great cook oh my god
i mean i know you deserve it it's a
little silly
how did you guys meet
um look at that handsome man um we met
doing a play together and we fell in
love immediately
and we dated secretly for the whole run
of the show
which was
very fun and exciting um and then like a
week before the show wrapped we totally
got caught
fully red-handed um
and
walking in on you guys we not quite um
our schedule was a little bit funny with
our saturday matinees and for some
reason would swap between two and three
o'clock
and so we were like yeah we have a three
o'clock baton and we were like having a
really lazy saturday and we'd ordered in
food and we like
had a shower together um and we were
just having a nice time and all of a
sudden we both looked at our phones and
we had like 25 missed calls
and it was 1 48
and we did not have a 3 o'clock that
night we had a 2 o'clock
matinee um and we were both in towels
with wet hair
and um
we
in that moment actually we were like we
kind of knew that we were meant to be
together because we were like this is
the first true crisis and we both were
like you call the cab i'm gonna get a
dress i'm gonna do this i'm gonna call
the stage manager like you boom boom
boom and we just like and we got there
with two minutes to spare and we went on
stage i think it was actually one of our
earliest curtains we went on at like
205.
but we fully walked in and we were like
um we were having lunch together
and everyone was like
really
lunch
[Music]
you